et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour les benjamines
[Musique]
ça prendra pas j'y arriverai pas guillon
non plus remarque
dion à l'autre qui gagnait plus que moi
de nombreux messages m'ont été adressés
suite à la dernière chronique dont un
très intéressant merci pour ce coup de
poignard au coeur que des milliers de
parents de victimes et de victimes de
pédophiles ont dû recevoir ce soir
devant votre édito à quand un édito sur
le viol collectif le lynchage raciste
les camps de concentration le massacre
des enfants en syrie alors je tenais à
remercier cette personne pour ses idées
de thèmes que je vous propose de
développer sans plus attendre
le lynchage raciste chaque jour en
france des gens mangent des pains au
chocolat
viol collectif ne verront pas ce terme
d'un autre oeil si on se contentait de
parler d'amour participatif
en ce qui concerne le massacre des
enfants en syrie alors là c'est un petit
problème impossible de s'en moquer
puisqu'à l'heure où je vous parle on
peut se demander s'il reste encore des
enfants en syrie
merci en tout cas pour que ces idées en
ce qui concerne les camps de
concentration ça sujet un peu plus
délicat mais on a trouvé une transition
puisque politiquement cette semaine au
congrès toulouse nisrine zaïbi militante
du ps a déclaré à la tribune du congrès
qu'elle avait la chance de pouvoir
s'exprimer au congrès du parti
national-socialiste
merci merci j'espère que désormais on
commencera enfin aborder dans la rue en
traitant d'humoristes de gauche
alors évidemment je ne voulais pas
parler du ps cette semaine parce que je
n'aime pas trop parler des gens qui
essayent de faire le même métier que moi
et qui arrivent mieux
parce que là c'est vrai on tient on
tient une perle hérault jean marx avec
l'allemand avec un capes de français ce
type est en train d'exploser cas
exceptionnel connaissait beaucoup de
mecs qui balance une info le matin qui
sont recadrés par un ministre dans les
cinq minutes et puisqu'ils se regarde
lui même quatre fois dans la journée
c'est par un amateur c'est sage et nick
watney excelle
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs héros je me dis pourquoi être
sérieux et invisible quand il suffit de
dire des conneries pour exister
je ne sais pas qui est son conseiller en
com et mais s'il en a il a dû se faire
les dents sur eva joly au raymond
domenech
toute façon je sens qu'on est parti pour
un moment là il a trouvé un créneau il
va user la semaine prochaine va revenir
quoi sur les congés payés dans deux mois
elle retour au franc et puis dans un an
inch allah sera capable de dire que
l'algérie française ça paraît tabou
mais bon ça c'est normal ces gens là il
découvre le pouvoir ça fait 11 ans qui
n'ont généré que des régions autant dire
pas grand chose la seule décision
visible que prend une région c'est quoi
remplacer un carrefour par un rond point
j'espère vraiment que quelqu'un a mis du
scotch sur le bouton nucléaire
pendant ce temps ce fameux duel que
passionne toute la france copé fillon
béret bleu contre blueberry et on dirait
de majorettes qui minaude et dans la
seule nuance sur résume pour l'un à dire
ouais moi j'y vais franco dans la
soudure et l'autre j'aimais pudeur mais
ça me rend pas moins coquines
bref
copé qui veut organiser des manifs pour
déstabiliser le gouvernement
comme si ce gouvernement avait besoin
d'une manif pour être déstabilisé
franchement quand on les voit on se dit
que même l'annoncé du retour de la
croissance serait capable de les faire
paniquer
une manif de droite ça va être quelque
chose ça à [ __ ] les jetons rsa c'est
l'insoutenable flik flak des mocassins
et le hurlement au vent des carrés
hermès
après la france qui gronde la france qui
fraude route alors le tout dans le
grincement sardonique des poussettes
chargé de prénom du xvième siècle et
léopold les matches tout ça le truc
alors évidemment le cortège ira terne à
la muette avec un cocktail dînatoire
place du trocadéro à la suite de quoi
dans un geste de protestation les
manifestants et mêleront leurs cartes
club med gym
avec des slogans que nous allons tous
gardé chevillée au corps sous les pavés
vinci garage
touche pas à ma mèche crs ss
heureusement
[Applaudissements]
non mais il ne faut pas désespérer ainsi
on considère que beaucoup de soixante
huitard ont fini dans la pub de la
finance qu'est ce qui nous dit que les
chats là ne vont pas finir dans
l'éducation nationale et la fonction
publique
avec ses fameux heures en fin de cortège
ont dispersé les manifestants les crs
les ont aspergés d'une autre colonne
premier prix
soit une manif de droite ça va pas être
bien méchant vers la fin il faut faire
quoi les racailles denis est dévalisé
des magasins de cachemire volet des
chouquettes
économie le choc de la compétitivité
alors c'est les patrons qui couine au
nom et au nom de la compétitivité mais
alors héros qui a eu cette jolie phrase
arrêtons dénigrer les chefs d'entreprise
car le mot entreprendre c'est un joli
mot
phonétiquement chômage c'est pas dégueu
non plus
on dirait un voyage sans le souci de la
valise perdu ou des contraintes horaires
que c'est pas c'est mon avis amour parce
qu'il faut bien parler de sa misère
sexuelle progresse en france eh oui en
effet selon une étude du parisien un
français sur deux n'arrive pas à se
chauffer correctement
amour toujours ça y est après tant que
ribéry n'est ni galant ni aimable ni
gentils
quelqu'un lui envoyer une fiche du
client avant d'y aller
s'attendait à quoi qui lui récitait un
poème de rimbaud en de changement de
position qui lui-même une ivg sous
péridurale pour la faire marrer
arrêtes tu fasses du jonglage au ballon
comme une otarie la marine landes je
sais pas une façon choisie ribéry pour
sa finesse à peu près aussi intelligent
que d'accrocher une caravane camping à
une bentley pour faire les 24 heures du
mans
[Applaudissements]
internationale canal+ c'est la semaine
usa ils disent pour faire un clin d'oeil
ok
c'est bon on a ce qu'il faut en fait
super
à toulon il ya eu des inondations et un
pauvre gars s'est noyé ses malheureux
quand on lui a remis une médaille
posthume du courage alors on cherche
encore le type qui n'a pas sauté pour
lui remettre la médaille vital du
pragmatisme
ceci était une fille qui vend pour six
cent mille euros sa virginité pour faire
des études de médecine alors ce n'est
qu'une pénétration vaginale elle est
prévoyante et se gardent l'anah lanka de
repêchage
[Applaudissements]
aucun rapport mais six mois avec sursis
pour une femme voilée
se pose alors cette question très
pratique si elle un comportement
dangereux en prison comment faire pour
la mettre en cellule d'isolement dans la
vraie punition serait quoi ça serait de
l'obliger à faire un mois de naturisme
au capital
l'a exclu
mais faut pas désespérer faux pas non
vraiment pas quoi il ya des bonnes
nouvelles la chancelière allemande a
inauguré un mémorial aux roms mémorial
conçue par l'artiste dani karavan
on dit que les clichés ont la vie dure
mais et alors
alors elle est pas belle la vie et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus